kylie jenner is expanding her family
once again i'm excited about it multiple
sources confirmed to et that the 24 year
old makeup mogul and her longtime beau
rapper travis scott are expecting their
second child together thank you one
source tells et that the couple is very
excited to welcome another baby and give
their three-year-old daughter stormy a
sibling i love you
[Music]
the source adds the couple has talked
about growing their family for a while
and have always been on the same page
about wanting more kids meanwhile a
second source is opening up about how
kylie is keeping a low profile during
her second pregnancy quote kylie loves
being pregnant and enjoyed her last
pregnancy out of the public eye she
wanted to be able to have some of that
same experience this time but it was not
the best kept secret everyone is so
happy for her she and travis are in a
great place and this is something they
talked about really planned for
baby
okay moving on as for kylie and travis
who have been on and off as a couple for
years a third source is shedding light
on their current dynamic explaining that
they're doing great adding that kylie
really feels like travis has gone out of
his way to reprove himself to her the
source also says the kardashian jenner
fam is very supportive of them getting
back together and really enjoys spending
time with him plus the famous fam has
taken notice that travis is striving to
be the best father and partner he can be
and they're very impressed congrats to
the happy couple and their growing
family
[Music]
you